marie thibeault bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors à la veille de la journée
internationale des cancers pédiatriques
vous alerter sur la hausse du nombre de
cas un des cancers chez chez les enfants
ces dernières années expliquez-nous
qu'est ce que vous avez observé
avis sur un territoire au sud loire de
la loire atlantique
du côté de sainte pazanne
et sur notre secteur depuis 2000 15 25
enfants ont déclaré un cancer est cette
enfant sont décédés comme je le disais
dans le reportage
nous avons alerté les autorités
sanitaires et celles ci ont conclu comme
vous avez lu qu'il n'y aurait pas de
recherches au delà de ce qu'ils avaient
fait à savoir un questionnaire à
destination des familles parce que ça
reste incroyable ce que 25 kazan c'est
une toute petite commune pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas c'est pas seulement
ça ne pas anne c'est les communes les
sept communes autour de sainte pazanne
mais c'est tout petit en effet en tout
cas un petit secteur 25 e enfant atteint
atteints de cancer et donc aujourd'hui
on
vous explique que ce n'est pas lié
forcément à à quelque chose qui
viendraient comme delà des pesticides ou
ce genre de chose qu'est ce qu'on vous
dit
alors nous on nous dit pas ça on nous
dit que eux
n'ont pas la capacité
à trouver la seule et l'unique cause
hein parce que leur manière de
rechercher c'est de trouver une seule et
unique cause sauf que quand on est sur
des secteurs comme les nôtres on a de
l'agriculture de la viticulture du
maraîchage dont des produits
phytosanitaires
tous différents les uns des autres on a
chez nous un grand nombre de champs
électromagnétiques
champs électromagnétiques extrêmement
basses tram en basses fréquences liée au
nombre d'éoliennes sur notre secteur
nous avons également un nombre de métaux
et de terreur très important donc on est
sur un cumul de facteurs de l'exposition
très important et nous autorités
sanitaires ne recherche pas le cumul
c'est à dire qu'il ne prenne en compte
qu'une seule cause si nous avions à
tchernobyl sur notre secteur il n'y
aucun problème mais à partir du moment
où il ya plein de facteurs
ensemble qui se cumulent les uns avec
les autres il décide de ne pas aller
chercher parce que c'est pas la
méthodologie de la france aujourd'hui on
prend pas en compte les effets cocktail
on prend pas en compte le cumul des
expositions et on ne prend pas en compte
la toxicité chronique de chaque produit
de chaque polluants on prend en compte
que les toxicité aiguë dont les normes
en france ce qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
trouver aujourd'hui que ce soit chez
nous ou ailleurs quelques causes des
situations de malformations ou de
cancers pédiatriques mais que vous
vraiment toute la méthodologie que vous
répondre les autorités justement quand
vous pointez du doigt cette méthodologie
aujourd'hui
ils nous disent qu'on a raison santé
publique france nous a dit clairement
que oui certainement que ce qui se passe
chez nous est liée à un grand nombre de
facteurs environnementaux qu'il faudrait
prendre tous sont contents mais que eux
dans leur méthodologie et dans leur
mission ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
donc ils ne peuvent pas le faire alors
vous étiez dans la rue justement devant
le ministère de la santé pour pointer du
doigt cette cette situation là vous avez
été reçus comment ça s'est passé
non hier c'était un mouvement de
sensibilisation
c'était un moment de regroupement de
rassemblement des familles notre projet
n'était pas du tout d'être reçu au
ministère s'étaient vraiment le lieu
symbolique parce que quand on parle de
cancer d'enfants parle de santé est ce
que nous nous souhaiterions c'est que
nos enfants
soient tous en bonne santé pas dans une
santé
on doit les guérir pas dans une santé on
doit les soigner mieux mais dans une
santé où il n'y a rien à faire ils vont
bien et en fait ils ne pourront aller
bien que si nous prenons en contre un
environnement sain et c'est ce que nous
c'est ce que nous souhaitons également
puisque stop au cancer de nos enfants
fait partie du collectif un crs
interassociatif pour la santé
environnementale et nous avons lancé une
pétition justement dans ce sens la prise
en charge aujourd'hui de ses enfants
atteints de cancer on en mai ou en
france
il ya de belles avancées ces derniers
mois puisque effectivement le
gouvernement a voté 20 millions d'euros
de rallonge sur la recherche maintenant
il faudra voir sur quel type de
recherche c'est 20 millions vont aller
la recherche clinique et
translationnelle
fondamentale évidemment mais j'ose
espérer qu'il y aura une partie sur la
recherche préventive parce qu'elle est
indispensable
et puis l'europe est en train de bouger
aussi sur ces questions donc c'est
vraiment le moment de se mobiliser dans
parler parce que demain c'est la journée
internationale des cancers de l'enfant
et cette journée est vraiment très
importante merci beaucoup marie
thibeault pour autres et témoignages ce
matin sur rtl france je le rappelle vous
êtes lanceuse d'alert fondatrice du
collectif stop au cancer de nos enfants